جوالك
الان وتشوف مده الاستجابه لايف ما يعني ما
يعرف الرقم
[موسيقى]
هذا سقراط من اذاعه ثمانيه وانا اعمل
الجريسي استضيف قاعده التحول وقاده
الاعمال وقاده الراي وسولف معهم على
المستجدات ومستهدفات رؤيه السعوديه 20 30
من زمان صرفنا قاده برامج تحقيق الرؤيه
فكانت عودتنا اليوم في برنامج جوده الحياه
مع الرئيس التنفيذ الاستاذ خالد البكر
ولان من زمان عنهم عن برامج تحقيق الرؤيه
فخدنا البدايه في التذكير بمفهوم البرامج
ايش علاقتها بالجهات التنفيذيه ايش
علاقتها همم ايش مرجعها اللي تاخذ منه
الاعتماد والموافقات والتموين وبعد ذلك
دخلنا في همم
مفهوم جوده الحياه التحديدا على ايش يعتمد
هل هو فقط ترفيه ورياضه ولا هو اوسع واشهر
من هذا المفهوم وتكلمنا على الوثيقه
الاولى والا الاساسيه والوثيقه الجديده
اللي اشتروها ليش الوثيقه الجديده ما عاد
فيها مؤشرات وارقام
محدده لقياس اداء المبادرات بعدين دخلنا
في حكايه التحول مسكنا القطاعات كامله من
قطاع التصميم الحضري وان كان مشققنا فيه
اللي هو يشمل التشوه البصري الازدحام
المروري جوده الطرق وغيرها وبعدين دخلني
على قطاع الرياضه وقطاع الثقافه وقطاع همم
التراث قطاع الترفيه وقطاع الامن وقطاع
السياحه في كل هذا القطاعات حول ناخذ اهم
ما تحقق ناقشنا بعض الاشياء اللي لم تتحقق
مثل دار جزيره الفنون في جده همم
معهد الفنون الملكي همم مدينه مائيه ثلاث
مدن ملاهي
مجموعه على المسارح همم وانديه الهواه هذه
مجموعه من مبادرات التي لم تتحقق فشرفنا
مع ضيفنا عن اسباب عدم التحقيق وفي الختام
كالعاده ختمنا بمجموعهم الثمينه مثل لسؤال
صاحبنا اللي يقول انا اعشق المباريات ابغى
احضر مباراه بدون ما تدخلوا فيها حفله
موسيقيه بالغصب همم فكيف رايهم في موضوع
الشريحه اللي ما هي مهتمه ببعض فعالياتهم
مهتمه فعاليات اخرى قاعدين اليوم يخسرون
هذا الاهتمام همم موضوع همم مكافحه
المخدرات ايش اهم ما تحقق في همم وغيرها
من اسئله اترككم مع الحوار حياك الله ابو
عبد الله
اهلا وسهلا وشكرا للصداقه في هذا البرنامج
المميز الجميل سعيد اليوم وان شاء الله
تكون حلقه يعني
ان شاء الله ابو عبد الله انت اليوم تقود
برنامج جوده الحياه لكنك قبل
المهمه كانت علاقه بك من مبادرات جوده
الحياه اعطنا كده لمحه سريعه على علاقتك
بالبرنامج قبل ما تصير البرنامج طبعا انا
بدات رحلتي مع رؤيه المملكه 2030 في وزاره
الرياضه كان وقتها طبعا الهيئه العامه
للرياضه تحت سمو الاميره ريما بنت بندر بن
سلطان في الاتحاد السعودي للرياضه للجميع
كان وقت اسماء الرياضه مجتمعيه وكنا نعمل
مع المبادرات برنامج جوده الحياه من زاويه
همم الرياضه
الهيئه العامه للرياضه وانتقلت طبعا من
الاتحاد الى همم عملت مع الامير عبد
العزيز بن تركي الفيصل في همم فورملائي
2018 كانت اول حدث عالمي همم رياضي استضاف
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه وحضرتك بهذا
الشرف مع طبعا سمو الامير عبد العزيز
والفريق العمل اللي كان موجود وقتها
فاعتقد هذه يعني بدايه علاقتي الرسميه
بالرؤيه يعني
برده لك علاقه فيه
رالي داكار من البدايات كنت من ضمن الفريق
المشكل من قبل سمو الامير للتخطيط له ولكن
يعني كحدث وقت السكيوشن او وقت التنفيذ
كنت وقت البرنامج
يعتبرون الناس هو اا
يعني نواه مصغره لبرنامج حياتي باغلى
مبادرات الثقافيه والرياضيه والترفيه كان
في كميه اشياء لاول مره تحدث شركه فعاليه
ايش تتذكر من كواليس هذيك الفعاليه
يعني كانت 18 سنه 2018
صراحه كان حدث استثنائي اذكر في التجربتنا
في همم
وزاره الرياضه
لما كلفت بالمهمه اذكر كانت 2018
والحدث كان في نوفمبر ديسمبر في نفس السنه
لكن في تراك جاهز لا نعرف بالضبط شنو نبغى
نسوي
فعملنا على التراك عملنا على اماكن اللي
يكون فيها الناس
العاديه على الفعاليات المصاحبه لها
المطاعم اللي استضفناها كان حدث انا اعتقد
انه الفورمه 2018 حدث يعني ما بغربطه بس
في جوده الحياه يمكن ما كانت الارتباط
مباشره بجوده الحياه لكن هذا الحدث غير
وجه الفعاليات في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بعدين بعدها شفنا المواسم وشفنا
عدد الاحداث اللي صارت بعدها
كنت ثلاثينات
والجزء من فريق شارك في تنظيم الفعليه
ومعك شباب كثير وشضيف لكم لما لما تشارك
كان
المعنى الحقيقي لحلم تحقيقه وشلون معنى
الحقيقي اللي احنا بنتحققه بتشوف الايفنت
اول مره نستضيف ايفنت عالمي بتشوف يعني من
اللاعبين او سائقين العالميين موجودين معك
ما كنا نشوف هذا الشيخ المملكه العربيه
السعوديه تشوف الفعاليات المصاحب الكونسرت
فعاليات الثقافيه المطاعم كانك اغلبها اول
مره يصير في المملكه احنا نشتغل على الحدث
كنت يجيني تساؤل في نفسي اقول هذا الحدث
صدق بيصير يعني ولا نحن قاعدين نحلم لكن
الدعم اللي كنا نشوفها من سمو سيدي ولي
العهد في الاجتماعات اللي كنا نلتقي فيه
للفورمولا اي همم كان دعم استثنائي وخلى
الحلم يكون واقع اذا بديت انا اربط انه
فعلا هذه الرؤيه الطموحه بالامكان
والاصرار بدي اشوفك والتمكين من سمو سيدي
ولي العهد ومن حتى الالتزام من قبل
الوزراء وفرق العمل همم ما في شك انه من
حقك ان شاء الله بوش اصعب لحظه وايش
المهاره اللي تقول انا بعد هذيك الفعليه
اصبحت يعني ما عاد اشيل هم المهاره الفنيه
اكتسبتها واختبرتها في الفعليه وخلاص
قصه صارت
بعد ما جهزنا تراك طبعا لما جينا جهزت
تراك نوع من الاسفلت معين للسباقات يعني
مو بس عادي فجهزنا التراك كانت جاهز تماما
وبقي على الحدث يعني كذا يوم
فنقطه الانطلاع في وقت مغرب قبل اربع خمس
ايام نتفاجا الى احد الشركات
بالراسكوب بره نطاق عمل المشروع ما عندنا
اي علاقه فيها جت في مغرب قصه الطريقه
طبعا انا اقول لك يعني
ههه حفلات شقه رياض كلها اجت عليك وقتها
طبعا كان مخالف ما كان عندي اذن فوقتها
الصراحه يعني كان تحدي شيء صعب وتعرف انت
لازم
لها يعني اشياء كثيره فهذا من الاشياء
اللي صراحه يعني كنا دائما نقول الله يستر
نبغى بس البنت يبدا طبعا مطر وبغيت كنسل
يعني احداث كثيره لكن الحمد لله تسهلت
الحمد لله احنا ابو عبدالله
برنامج جوده الحياه همم
وانت ضميته في 2020
عام 2020
قبل ثلاث شهور والبرنامج هذا يمكن يعتبر
البرامج
قاعدين يشوفون في شيء حياتهم بشكل سريع
مباشر همم
فخلنا نذكر الناس احنا من زمان ما استضفنا
احد من من برامج تحقيق رؤيه فخلنا كل
الناس واشي برامج تحقيق الرؤيه وايش في
الضغط برنامج جوده الحياه طبعا اليوم احنا
لما نتكلم عن رؤيه المملكه 2030 نتكلم على
عدد من الاهداف الاستراتيجيه 96 هدف
استراتيجي وسندت ل 12 برنامج لتحقيق اا
هذه الاهداف اللي هي طبعا تحقيق رؤيه
المملكه 2030
فجات البرامج طبعا في اللجنه الاستراتيجيه
لما نتكلم حكمه في لجنه الاستراتيجيه تحت
مكتب الاداره الاستراتيجيه بعدين في 12
برنامج اللي يتعاملون مع الجهات التنفيذيه
فاحنا نتعامل مع الجهات التنفيذيه من خلال
التخطيط التمويل والمتابعه للتاكد من هذه
الجهات تعمل مع بعض او حتى لوحدها لتحقيق
الهدف المرجو من همم هذه الجهه فاليوم في
رؤيه المملكه في 12 برنامج اللي قلت لك
طبعا احنا لما نجيء على نتكلم عن برنامج
جوده الحياه او زي ما قلت انت برنامج يمكن
قري للناس ننظر لجوده الحياه من جانبين
واذا اذنت لي بفصل فيها
طبعا في مفهوم جوده الحياه احنا لما نتكلم
عن مفهوم جوده الحياه نتكلم على المفهوم
العام لجوده الحياه دي لامس كل شخص
فنعتقد او نرى يعني انه لامس انه اليوم
القياده اياده الله
مهتمه بجوده حياه الانسان في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه واولت هذا الجانب اهتمام
وانعكس هذا الاهتمام في رؤيه 20 30
سيده ولي العهد في مختلف الاصعده فتوفر
السكن هذا اولويه وجوده حياه
التنميه القدرات البشريه وتنميه الانسان
والاهتمام في الانسان جوده حياه
كفاءه الدوله وعمل الدوله من خلال تحول
الوطنيه
للانسان جوده حياه
وعليها قيس طبعا اليوم احنا نتكلم عن
مشروع دوله جينا احنا في برنامج جوده
الحياه في 2018 لما عطله رجعنا لاهم
المؤشرات العالميه فجينا قلنا اليوم نبغى
نعرف جوده الحياه ونضبط هذا المفهوم
فرجعنا لست مؤشرات عالميه لعله ابرازها
تقريبا
عندي نمط حياه وانا اقصد في الخيارات
المتاحه في الترفيه والرياضه والثقافه
وغيره من المطر الحياه
وعندي طال عمرك قابليه العيش اللي هي
المعايير الحضريه الاساسيه
للملائمه للانسان من تعليم وصحه وامن
وغيرها فالجناح ففي جناحين قابليه العيش
وهذا في الاساسيات تعليم صحه سكن نظيفه كل
ما يخص بنيه تحتيه اشياء اساسيه تعزز من
المطر
الثاني نمط الحياه خيارات يعني انا لما
ابغى اقضي وقت فراري واعمق من ذلك مباشره
قبل لا يطلق البرنامج
تحسين نمط الحياه وفي 2018 لما اطلق
البرنامج سمي البرنامج ببرنامج جوده
الحياه بعد ما وصلنا للمفهومين من 2018 في
بدايات البرنامج بدا البرنامج باربع اهداف
قطاعات رئيسيه تحت البرنامج اللي هي رياضه
وثقافه
نمط الحياه من هزاويه وان نرى قابليه
العشق في ما يخدم
الثلاث قطعات هذه فعلشان كده تيجي لما
تيجي تقيس نمط الحياه تلقى اليوم عندي في
الرياضه في الثقافه في الترفيه عملنا على
بناء منظومه متكامله
اما تفعيل قطاعات جديده اما قطاعات موجوده
لم تفعل بالطريقه المامونه في الرؤيه اما
تمكين للكوادر البشريه اشتراك للقطاع
الخاص او تمكين للمراه
من ثلاث قطاعات هذه كيف انا ممكن اعززها
وقطعنا الحمد لله شرط كبير في ثلاث قطاعات
فهذه كانت البدايه
ظاهرها نمط مع الوقت همم ارتحت اللجنه
الاستراتيجيه اللي هي طبعا المشرفه على
جميع برامج الرؤيه انه ثلاث قطاعات هذه
تؤثر وتتاثر بعده قطاعات اخرى موجوده في
رؤيه المملكه بس في برامج ثانيه
اولها السياحه انا اليوم لم استضيف
فعاليات رياضيه عالميه كبيره او فعاليات
ترفيهيه او غيرها
تجذب سياح وتطلب انه موجود منظومه متكامله
سياحيه تساهم في نجاح هذه الاستضافات
فانتقل لنا قطاع السياحه
طبعا بعدها ارتحت اللجنه الاستراتيجيه
ايضا بعد المناقشات انه القطاع البلدي يجب
ان ينتقل برنامج
قبل عام ونصف تقريبا فهذه رحلتنا في جوده
الحياه
كبر برنامج
ممتازه يعني احنا هنمشي عليها شويه
بس ابو عبد الله يمكن انا بافترض انه في
واحد يسمعنا ويقول ايش دخلكم يعني الدوله
ايش دخلها بين نمط حياتي انا ليش ما يعني
تركز على الصحه والتعليم
انك انت تهتم بجوده حياتي وايش يفرق معي
اذا عندي خيارات ترفيه سياحه وثقافه اليوم
الدوله
ايد الله داخله او عامله تغيير في كل
القطاعات قطاع الصحه عندي تحويل برنامج
كامل متكامل برنامج رؤيه اللي هو برنامج
تحول قطاع الصحي عندي في الاسكان زي ما
ذكرت لك برنامج كامل للاسكان معني
بالاسكان فانا اليوم لما اجي اتكلم عن
جوده الحياه انا اتكلم عن فتح اقتصاديات
جديده بمعنى اليوم انا لما استضيف فعاليات
كبيره ولا لما تطلع تاشيره السياحيه انا
اليوم قاعد اخلق اقتصاد جديد المرشد
السياحي ما كان موجود اول او اذا كان
موجود ما كان بالعدد اللي يحتاج انا اليوم
لما اتكلم عن تنظيم الفعاليات العالميه
لما اتكلم عن مشاركه الرياضيه في الخارج
عن استضافه الافلام القطاع الافلام
السينما وغيرها انا جالس اخلق اقتصاد
متكامل اضمن فيه التنوع اضمن في خلقه
وظائف للمملكه فالانسان اليوم بتشوفها من
ناحيه اقتصاديه انا قاعد افتح اقتصاديات
جديده ما كانت موجوده بالاضافه لاني انا
لما اوفر خيارات جديده ما هو لازم بره
عندك خيارات في البلد كثيره تخليك تقضي
وقتك يعني اول ما كنا نلاحظ انه ما في
خيارات كثير على اليوم ما اقدر في وقت
فراغي في المساء ولا في الويكند وفي نهايه
الاسبوع اقدر اروح له اليوم الخيارات
كثيره فهينا جاء دور جوده الحياه يعني
اعجز من هذه الخيارات لها بعد اقتصادي لها
بعد اجتماعي ولها بعد حتى على مستوى رضاك
الشخصي فانت اليوم لما يكون حتى لو انت من
غير المستفيدين مباشره من الاقتصاديات هذه
لكن لم يصير انت عندك خيارات هالجانب انت
بالعكس يعني عكس هذا على عملك على بيئتك
على مجتمعك على اسرتك يعني عاكس حتى لما
نتكلم في
ممارساتك الصحيه السليمه من لما عندي همم
اعمل على اني ارفع نسبه همم ممارسه
الرياضه لك هتخفف في فرصه الصحه من جهه
ثانيه فانا اليوم مضطر اذا مارست الرياضه
انك تروح
وان شاء الله تراجع المستشفيات لانه نسبه
الوقايه اعلى من انك شخص غير رياض مهمل
بتكون لك اكيد همم احتياج للمستشفيات اكثر
من الشخص اللي همم الرياضي ولو بنستكمل
حكامتها انتم اذا ما تسمعون للجهات انتم
تدفعون لي لجنه الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الشوط الثانيين بالضبط صحيح ومسؤولين عن
تصميم ومتابعه مبادره تحقيق رؤيه مع
الجهاز
خلينا ناخذ مثال على كيف تعملون يعني خذ
لي اي مبادره وقل لي اشتغلتوها انتم
والجهه المعنيه عشان نفهم كيف تصلون الى
مبادره كيف تحددون المستهدفاتتها وشلون
تنولونها وشلون تابعونها نبغى ناخذ رحله
مبادره طيب ولو طلب صراحه
طيب اليوم همم في العزيز من المبادرات
طبعا المستهدفات مسدسات رؤيه المملكه ولا
يمكن المساس في هذه المستهدف لا يمكن اني
يعني لا يمكن المساس بهذه المستهدفات يعني
سمو ولي العهد الله يحفظها حريص كل الحرس
انه هذه مسدسات
الاشياء اللازمه لتحقيق خادم الصدفات
فاحنا والجهات ما لنا عذر
اللي يصير انه عندنا انا مساعفات وعندي
همم بعض المبادرات باسندت لي من برنامج
اخر جتني جاهزه فبدئنا يعني نراجعها من
ناحيه هل اليوم هذه المبادره بصياغتها في
عام 2016 او 2017 مناسبه للتغيرات اللي
قاعد تصير في جوده الحياه فتلقانا نجلس
مثلا مع وزاره الرياضه او مع وزاره
الثقافه ونبدا نناقش مثلا المشاركه
الثقافه او نشرت ثقافه في الخارج اليوم
وزاره الثقافه عند اعمال كثيره في هذا
الجانب وجلسنا مع وزاره الثقافه وقلنا
تعالوا
الان هذه المبادره هل هذه المبادره لها
حاجه لوجودها ولا ممكن نكتفي باعمال
الوزاره انه الوزاره عندها اعمال تقوم
بهذا الجانب وبتحقق هذا المستهدف وباخذ
كمثال مبادره ومتاثره يمكن يعني همم
الحمد لله
بس خلينا نتكلم عن شيء متعثر
واتوقع هذا مالا يعني هذا الموضوع ااه يهم
ناس كثير
موضوع الفنون الفنون الفنون الجراج الفنون
في المدارس
المحوريه ما في شك ايه طبعا اليوم انا
عندنا مبادره للفنون المبادره هذه تعثرت
فشكلنا فريق عمل
بتوجيه من لجنه البرنامج من وزاره التعليم
او وزاره الثقافه وبرنامج جوده الحياه ان
نجلس ونشوف سبب هذا التاثر فعملنا حوكمه
همم
للمبادره شكلنا فريق فني وفريق تنفيذي
وفريق استراتيجي لاعاده ترتيب هذه
المباراه
وبدانا نعرف انه في جهات بره منظومتنا
جوده الحياه يعني جهات حكوميه ما هي
موجوده لازم تكون موجوده زي هيئه التقويم
التعليم
لان المبادره لازم يكون لها اطار معتمد
ولازم يكون لها مناهج معتمده فرجعنا مع
وزاره التعليم وزاره الثقافه مشكورين
وعملنا على اعاده هذه المبادره الى المسار
الصحيح اللي خليني اليوم اقول ان المناهج
الخاصه بالفنون بتكون خلال اقل من سنه
جاهزه ان شاء الله للتدريس هذه واحده من
المبادرات المتعثره اللي احنا طبعا اليوم
عندي لجنه برنامج برئاسه معالي الاستاذ
احمد بن عقيل الخطيب وعضويه اصحاب السموم
والمعالي من مختلف الجهات الحكوميه
معاليه والاعضاء بشكل كامل الاجتماع معنا
بشكل دوري في المدرسه عندنا اجتماعات
شهريه على مستوى اللجنه عندنا انا عندي
شخصيا وفريق العمل الاجتماعي مع الاعضاء
بعض الوزراء اسهم معهم بشكل اسبوعي مره
الى مرتين في خطوط التواصل همم مفتوحه
اقدر اقول لك طول ايام الاسبوع حتى في
نهايه الاسبوع
والنقاشات اللي تصير في اللجنه
لجنه حريصه كل الحصن هتشوف اهداف
الاستراتيجيه وين وصلت فيها مؤشرات اداء
وين وصلت ماذا تقدم المبادرات وصاروا
يقولولي
خلنا نجلس ونناقشه على طاوله واحده ونشوف
كل واحد كيف ممكن يخدم الثاني من جهه
حكوميه بحيث انه نحقق الهدف مثل اللي صار
في التعليم والثقافه
[موسيقى]
في عصر رقمي متغير باستمرار المواكبه هي
اساس النجاح ولاننا رواد المستقبل
[موسيقى]
جميل ولما اتكلم عن برنامج هنتكلم على
هيئه مركز لجنه
احنا مركز برنامج جوده الحياه طبعا اي
جهاز اي برنامج حكومي يجب ان يكون محترم
في جهاز ولكن اليوم لان جوده الحياه ما
شاء الله داخله في قطاعات كثير فلا يمكن
احتضانها في جهاز معين دون الاخر فليذا
استحدث مركز واسند لهذا المركز ترتيبات
التنظيميه همم تخص الهوايات وعندنا الان
خطه للتوسع في هذا المركز بدانا ندخل مع
الجامعات الحكوميه والخاصه داخل وخارج
المملكه في شركات علشان ندخل في مراكز
بحثيه معهم همم تخدم جوده الحياه كمافهوم
وليس كبرنامج فقط على مستوى المملكه كم
عدد الموظفينكم
85% سعوديه
عندكم همم
رهيب
متوسط العماره عندنا
واحد منهم موجود ترى
الله يعطيه الصحه والعافيه 34 سنه
44% ااا حسب اليوم 44% هم من اخواتنا همم
الموظفات في برنامج 56% من الذكور ونفتخر
معتز انهم 100% السعوديين ونفتخر انه
الرؤيا مكنتنا كشباب همم انه نخدم وطننا
انه اتاهت الفرصه لكلها اولها الشباب
والشابات انهم يساهمون في تحقيق رؤيه
المملكه
الاولى انتم عندكم وثيقه اولى صدرت 2018
وحدثت شجره الوثيقه الثانيه في هذه السنه
في شيء ملف انه كثير كثير جدا من
المبادرات خط الاساسي 2018 او البدايه هذا
هو الرقم حقنا الهدف بعد ثلاث سنوات هو
نفس الرقم وباذكر مثال اللي انا احبه وانت
تعرفه زين
الحمد لله مؤشر
هنطال عمرك عشان بس لي اللي سمعنا ويفهم
الفكره مؤشر ازحام خط الاساس انه سكان
الرياض ياخذون 39 ساعه في الزحام همم
والهدف في 20 20 39 ساعه نفس خط الاساس
وقس عليها اشياء كثيره خط الاساس هو نفسه
المستهدف وايش يعني مثل هذا
التصميم من المبادره بطريقه هذه طيب
اليوم همم اكيد انه الاتحاد
في وقته صح لكن
على عدد ساعات معين في ظل تغيرات كبيره
تصير في الرياض هل الرياض اليوم في نفس
الرياض عام 2017 اكيد لا اليوم عندي حديقه
الملك سلمان همم العمل قائم فيها عندي
حدائق الملك عبد الله المسار الرياضي
القديه الدرعيه ومشاريع كبرى في مدينه
الرياض قاعده تحدث في الوقت اللي احنا
نتكلم فيه فهل الرياضه اللي تحولت الى
ورشه عمل
طبيعي هذا بصير له اثر في مده التنقل صار
عندنا هدف انه نحافظ على عدم زياده هذا
الرقم يا ريت تنتهي هذه المشاريع او اللي
قاعده تصير فراغ في مختلف في الرياض يعني
في مختلف مناطق الرياض او حتى في غير
الرياض في جده ولا في الخبر اوغيرها
فطبيعي لما المدينه تتحول الى ورشه عمل
مشاريع ما شاء الله في كل مكان عدد زوار
يزيد سواء من زوار او سواء حتى من سكان
اللي انتقلوا للرياض فانا لما حافظ على
الرقم طبيعي انه اعتبر هذا بالنسبه لي
انجاز فمش خطا هذا ما هو خطا ابدا في ظل
انه حتى لما تشوف الخيارات اللي قاعده
تصير في مدينه الرياض من فعاليات رياضيه
وثقافيه وترفيهيه من المؤتمرات يعلن عنها
كل اسبوع تجد انه الزوار من المناطق
المحيطه للرياضه حتى من مختلفه حتى من
خارج المملكه قاعدين يزيد يوم عن يوم في
محافظه على هذا الرقم في ظل الازدياد في
ظل المشاريع يعتبر النجاح همم في سؤال
ثاني على الموضوع كيف تصمم المؤشرات يعني
مثلا احد الضيوف اللي تعرفهم
كان يقول انه انا عندي مبادره محطوط عليه
علامه حمراء اني انا ما حققتها وتقييمه
متاثر فيها لاني بس ما خلصت اخر فقره اللي
هي اقامه احتفال
حفل الختامي طيب سوينا خلصنا كل شيء بس
صمم المؤشر بانه لازم اسوي حظر ختامي عشان
تحسب طيب الحمد لله
في كل مبادره في وثيقه لهذه المبادره
ومعالم مسجل على كل مباره وفي برنامج جوده
الحياه لما صممنا المبادرات من
مرحله الدراسه الين مرحله الانتهاء بالحفل
الختامي واتفقنا مع الجهه على همم المعالم
المعالم الخاصه بالمبادره ووثقناها في
مركز اداء لقيس المبادرات صار ما عندنا اي
تنازل على مستوى اي معلم حتى وان كان هذا
الختامي
فحرسين كل الحرص ان اي مبادره تم تصميمها
وفرنا لها الامكانيات وفرنا لها التمويل
وفرنا لها الدعم اللي نقدر عليه فبالتالي
لازم تنفذ 100% ما نرضى باقل يعني ما نقدر
99% انا عندي مؤشرات لما تقاس 98% تظهر
اصفر ما تظهر اخضر وهي 98
طالما اعتمد توفر التمويل لا تناسب الا
اذا كان في سبب يعني مثلا يجيك سبب
الدراسه ولا نتخذ احنا فيه حسب الحكم
امانه في القرار احنا نرفع اللجنه
الاستراتي اللجنه الاستراتيجيه ترى مدى
مناسبه همم
جزء من من الوثيقه المطوره صح او او
النسخه المحدده
الوثيقه الاولى لما اطلقت الوثيقه الاولى
اطلقت بتفاصيل كثيره وعدت صفحات حتى يمكن
اعلى من همم
الوثيقه الثانيه
العديد من البرامج ما اطلق على سبيل
المثال تحقيق القدرات البشريه همم
بتاعه الصندوق الصندوق الاستثمارات العامه
كثير منها ما كان موجود واسند الى بعض
المشاريع
فصار عندي فرق بين وثيقه الاولى والثانيه
لانه الوثيقه الاولى حصرنا فيها كل ما
يمكن قياسها همم لجوده الحياه كان محصور
في الوثيقه الاولى فلما جت الوثيقه
الثانيه عملنا التحديث وسندت المؤشر اللي
يخص برنامج اخر راح للبرنامج المختصر
المشروع اللي كان موعود عندي وهو اليوم
تحت الصندوق اسند اللي همم الشركه المختصه
في صندوق الاستثمارات العامه وما زال طبعا
يقاس من قبل جهات اعلى منها لكن انا
مشكلتي يعني الوثيقه الجديده اوضح اسهل
ابسط صراحه هذا يعني يحسب لكم مشكلتي هي
غياب الشفافيه يعني
كانت حتى عدد التذاكر المباعه حاطين الهدف
الوثيقه الجديده ما فرق قام ما حد يقدر
يمسك عليكم شيء ههه
لانشاء الطرق ومواقف السيارات والطرق
الحضاريه والجسور والانفاق والميادين اخي
المدن وتشمل مبادره تنفيذ اعمال الزفته
والوصف والاناره والسلام المروريه وانشاء
الجسور والانفاق الى اخر مبادره ابمسك رقم
واحد ابي امسك مؤشر واحد ما في ما حد يمسك
عليكم شيء في هذا ههه
وثيقه الجديده ما في ارقام ما في ما تقدر
تقيسها كمواطن يمكن انتم داخليا عندكم بس
جزء من كلامه ويعاهد في مؤتمر اطلاق
الرؤيه ان احنا نشرنا كل شيء يلا يا مجتمع
انتم ساعدونا في المتابعه بس في الوثيقه
الجديده شيء
عندي 44 مؤشر رسمي موجود في الوثيقه
الجديده يقيس كل القطاعات اللي موجوده
عندي ايضا لما ارجع وقارن بين الوثيقه
القديمه الوثيقه الجديده في اشياء زي ما
قلت لك راحت البرامج اخرى في الوثيقه
الجديده عندي 44 مؤشر قيس كل القطاعات مع
موجود في المستهدف ان كان موجود مساعده 23
او25 او حتى المسادفات الرؤيه في 20 30 في
44 مؤشر بس كل القطاعات اللي
المستهدف هل شفت انها تسبب لكم احرار
الجهاز
المبادرات قد تتغير وبشرح لك كيف تتغير قد
تتغير انه اليوم انا اتعامل مع منافسه
عالميه على مستوى جوده الحياه فانا لازم
اكون دائما يعني في حراك في حراك مواكب
للتغيرات اللي قاعده تصير على مستوى جوده
الحياه في الخارج سواء في مختلف القطاعات
اللي موجوده ااا اليوم تبع البرنامج
انه ما نوصل لهدف اللي احنا نبغى نوصل له
الحزمه الثانيه
يعني تحول الوطني كان 2020 بعدين الى 25
طب انتم اليوم من متى الى متى وش وش
اطاركم الزمني احنا طبعا عندنا المبادرات
اغلبها انت في عام 2025 البرنامج حسب خطه
الحاليه الى 2023 ومن المؤكد انه بنشتغل
مع مكتب الاداره الاستراتيجيه لمناقشه
المستقبل رؤيه المملكه اوكي فهو الان
مبادرات الى 25
خلينا ندخل ابو عبد الله على الجزء اللي
يمكن يهم كثيرين وهو له بحلقه اليوم حكايه
التحول همم وانت حبيت اننا نقسمها
بالقطاعات فهو الشيء القطاع اللي تبغى
نبدا فيه نبغى نعرف وين كنا
بالقضاء
يعني
ههه
بس ههه
هو موضوع دخول ثلاث مدن افضل 100 مدينه في
العالم هذا من احد اشعه الرؤيه حتى همم
انا دخلت على المؤشر نفسه دفعت اشتراك
لانه المؤشر بفلوس دفعت اشتراك طلعت
بياناتنا واكتشفت انه كل الثلاث مدن
الرياض جده الخبر متراجعه في هذا المؤشر
طبعا همم احنا لما نيجي نتكلم عن قياس اا
ثلاث مدن من ضمن افضل مئات المدينه احنا
ما نتكلم عن مؤشر واحد بعينه احنا نقيس
بعده مؤشرات ولا نقيس بس في القطاع البلدي
نقيس يعني عده همم
من عده همم يعني من اكثر من جهه يعني عندي
اليوم الامن والامن الشخصي للشخص
وهذا يؤثر في جوده حياه او في تقييم
المدينه في همم من ضمن افضل 100 مدينه
سعاده الانسان وتقدير السعاده كنا ترى
الاربعه عند الاربعه مدن ما خلتني ذكرى
كلها من افضل يعني في تقرير السعاده
العالمي
اذا ما خانتني الذاكره الرياض وجده ومكه
والمدينه
وضع في خمسه بس انا ناسيه المعذره لكن
عندنا مدن في تقرير السعاده العامه فانا
لما اشوف زاويه تقرير السعاده العالمي
ماشي كويس وهذا يدل على ان نمط الحياه الي
عملنا عليه حقق الاثر المطلوب ولما اجي في
المؤشرات الثانيه عندي في الامن ودف اتكلم
في الامن
نتكلم في الامن حرصنا انه مع زملائنا
وشركائنا في وزاره الداخليه بانه نغطي
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بخدمه 911 او 9
1 1 بحيث انه كل المكالمات الطارئه تروح
لهذا المركز وحرصنا على جوده هذا المركز
يكون على اعلى جوده وزملاء في همم وزاره
الداخليه قد اداء حسن في هذا الجانب وترفع
جوالك تكلم معي وانا وانا الان وتشوف مده
الاستجابه لايف ما يعني حتى يمكن يعرف
تجرب وتكلم وتمد يتكلم
طيب ايش اقول لهم
اسال اي سؤال في بالك
وشوف مده الاستجابه
[موسيقى]
سلام عليكم
القطاعات اللي يغطيها هذا الرقم
هل الحوادث هل هي الاسعاف هل هي الدفاع
المدني
شكرا جزيلا
والله
في اقل من ثلاث ثواني حرصنا انه هذا حرصنا
انه تسعه واحد واحد يغطي كل الحالات
الطارئه كانت اسعاف الدفاع المدني مرور
شرطه او غيرها
ويطلع منه كميه بيانات ما تتخيلها هذا
خلانا نحلل حتى الاحياء في منطقه في
المناطق الموجود فيها 911 وعلى سبيل
المثال منطقه الرياض
فساعدنا حتى في دراسه موجوده الحياه ما
كان موجود في منطقه مكه المكرمه في اطار
معين ولكن عملنا التجربه الان لتغطيه
المملكه
طبعا بتوسع وما هو بس في استقبال البنات
اطلع بياناتك اقدر احل منها اقدر احلل انا
اليوم عندي الحي الفلاني نسبه مشاجره
عاليه بنات انا عندي هنا في مشكله لازم
ادرسها من بعد اجتماعي عندي حي اخر في سطو
عندي حي الحمد لله الامن يعني اللهم لك
الحمد يعني نسبه التقاس الى الان كلها
مرضيه جدا لكن قاعدين نجهز انه ما
يصير عندنا بكره شيء مفاجئ في هذا الجانب
فعلشان كده تلقانا يعني اليوم همم نطلع
بيانات ودراسات دقيقه جدا حتى تساعدنا في
توزيع اماكن سيارات الامن فممكن انا
تلقاني في منطقه معينه محتاجه كثف فيها
منطقه اقل ترفع من كفاءه همم العمل في
القطاع الامني وبنرجع لموضوع الثلاث مدن
اليوم انتم كيف تعرفون اذا الهدف هذا تحقق
او لا طبعا عندنا عده معاشرات انا عندي
مستوى الرضا عن همم
الامن عندي همم تقرير السعاده العالمي
عندي مستوى الرضا عن نظافه المدن عند
المستوى همم عن رضا عن الخدمات المقدمه في
المدن والقطاع البلدي فعندي اكثر من مؤشر
اقيس فيه وبناءا على هذه المؤشرات ابدا
اعرف هل انا قاعد اتقدم في المدينه او لا
يعني يمكن واحده من الاشياء اللي دائما
تاخذ على هذا المستهدف انه طيب في باقي كم
كم عشرات المده في السعوديه ليش ترك على
ثلاث مدن انكم تحسنون جوده الحياه فيها
طيب ماذا عن بقيه هدى المملكه طبعا احنا
همم الاهتمام في رؤيه المملكه 2030 وفي
برنامج جوده الحياه تحديدا على كافه مدن
المملكه طبعا لما اجي اقيس في المدن مختلف
في المدن كل المدن يقدم فيها نفس الخدمات
اللي تقدم في المدن الرئيسيه ولكن كيف نفس
الخدمات
اليوم عندي في المدن الرئيسيه طبيعي انه
تلقى اهتمام اعلى ميزانيات اعلى طبعا نظرا
لانها مدن مديونيه لعدد فيها كبيره فالطلب
اعلى من المدن اللي اقل منها ولكن لما اجي
على اي مبادره عندي قطاع السينما على سبيل
المثال قطاع السينما لما اطلق في المملكه
اليوم القطاع السينما في اكثر من 55 دار
سليمان تغطي تسع مناطق من مناطق المملكه
طبعا الموضوع يخضع للعرض والطلب
واقتصاديات السوق اللي يتحكم يعني احنا
وصلنا نبغى وخلاص تركناه للقضاء فهي اربع
مناطق ما جاهزه
ما في طلب ما في تلقى الطلب ما يرتقي لانه
القطاع الخاص بيفتح شهيه القطاع الخاص انه
يستثمر فيه مع التاكيد انه انا اللي اعرفه
انه في الاتجاه لتغطيه جميع مناطق المملكه
من قبل القطاع الخاص واحنا بعد صرنا نتدخل
احنا اليوم دورنا انه نفتح هذا القطاع
انهمكن هذا القطاع نتاكد انه تشريعات
الملائمه موجوده في هذا القطاع وبناء عليه
همم القطاع يبدا ينطلق وصلناه للمستوى او
المساعده في المطلوب من قبل البرنامج جوده
الحياه
فديوم تجد انه عندي مثلا الاماكن التراثيه
الاماكن التراثيه كانت احصر كل الاماكن
الثلاثيه في المملكه قاعد اسجل المواقع
وقاعد همم اطور من البنيه التحتيه حق هذه
مواقع التراثيه
واتاكد انها قابله للزياره وهذه منتشره في
مختلف المناطق المملكه
من الاشياء اللي بتستغربها لما جينا في
لما نقدر نقطاع البلدي بدانا نحلل القطاع
البلدي
الحدائق والمساحات العامه في المدن غير
الرئيسيه اعلى من المدن الرئيسيه
يعني اليوم لما تروح وتشوف مثلا في منطقه
جيزان واجهات البحريه والحدائق الموجوده
على اعلى مستوى ما هذا ترى ما يعني انه
احنا اهتمينا هناك وتركنا المناطق المدن
الرئيسيه لكن العمل المطلوب مننا طبيعه
عمل البنيه التحتيه ما هي بزي نمط الحياه
اللي انت تقدر تبين اثرك فيه اسرع من
البنيه التحتيه ولكن همم في عمل كبير قائم
في القطاع البلدي في المدن الرئيسيه فعندك
مثلا على سبيل المثال في جده واجهه
البحريه اليوم الوجه البحريه على اعلى
مستوى ما يعني انه احنا بس وصلنا هناك
بنوقفنا احنا نكمل عندنا في الرياض في
كثير من الاماكن المشي اللي تم توفيرها
ومازلنا في البدايه في هذا القطاع في همم
مبادره التي تظهري عن موضوع نسبه رضا
المستفيدين عن جوده الطرق هذه خط الاساسي
في 20 كان 40%
هدفكم في 2023 ترفعونها النسبه الى
51% الناس مره متضايقه ومزعجه من من جوده
الطرق وهذه قاعده تفرق فعلا فعلا في
جوده حياتي اذا انا بطلع من البيت واشوف
الشوارع بالطريقه هذه وقاعده تتلف سيارتي
وقاعده تاثر على انسيابيه حركتي حتى انا
مثلا كشخص مقتني سيارات رياضيه ما ما اقدر
اتهنى بهذا النوع من السيارات
لكل الشرائح موضوع جوده الطرق قاعده يعني
قاعده تزعج الناس مره
تحقق في الموضوع طبعا لما نتكلم عن القطاع
البلدي يتكلم عن جوده طارق تحديدا العمل
القائم في طرق المملكه العربيه السعوديه
عمل كبير اليوم المملكه همم قاره فالاثر
فيها ما راح يكون اثر سريع همم
يلامس الجميع في يعني بشكل سريع احنا
سافلات اكثر من مليون ونصف كيلو متر من
الشوارع عندنا سافرت يعني العديد من الطرق
اليوم تروح بس مر على مناطق كثير في المدن
الرئيسيه تلقى انه فعلا همم في كثير من
الاحياء جاري اعاده سفلتها هذا نتكلم على
كجود الطرق بس ليش اللي بيقولوا لنا
المشاهدين الحين ما وصلنا لن نبغى ما
وصلنا
شفتوها ترى الان في شركات قاعد تحفر فيها
عشان كذا عملنا الان عندنا عمل القائم على
التاكد من انه الانظمه ملائمه على انه
فعلا الامانات تطبق هذه الانظمه وتلزم
وتغرب المقاولين اللي يعملون بدون ترخيص
وممكن في البدايه قلت لك القصه اللي انا
هكذا يعني هذا هو مشروع مخالف اليوم احنا
لازم يكون في عندنا نظام وهذا اللي عملنا
عليه انه في نظام همم
يحاسب المخالف وفي اليه واضحه لرصد همم
المخالفات الان احنا في تجارب حتى استخدام
اليات جديده معالجه لرصه الشوهات المصريه
عشان نقدر نعالج
كمان بالنسبه لهم وصلتهم من المستهد ال
51% طب احنا من المساعدات هذه المشتركه مع
برامج ثانيه لانه نقل في اشعه وزاره النقل
ما هي تبعنا اوكي ماشي خليني اتكلم على
تصميم الحضري
ونتكلم على همم يعني معدل نصيب الفرد معدل
نصيب الفرد من الساحات العامه وصلنا
للمستهدف ولكن اليوم الطموح اعلك كان الخط
الاساسي
48 متر مربع لكل فرد اليوم وصلني الى 4.65
وتجد انه في المدن طبعا احنا ناقصناه على
الان بنغير طريقه القياس عشان توضح اكثر
يوضح اكثر اكثر لما اخذها كمتوسط على
مستوى المملكه تلقى المدن الترفيه اللي
بان فيها الاهتمام صارت نسبه ساعات في
عاليه مقارنه في المدن الرئيسيه فالان
بنقيس على مستوى كل مدينه عشان لما يطلع
معي المؤشر
ما يصير المؤشر رقم عالي وتقول لي والله
انا ما شفت يا خالد
موجود اليوم في موقع البلديه لما تدخل على
حي الخزامه ولا على حي العليا ولا على اي
حي تجد انه مكتوب لك كم المعدل اليوم في
هذا الحي من هنا احنا نبدا نحط التاركس
اللي نرفعها وجنس نعمل على هذا الجانب
فهذا مؤشر موضوع نسبه المساحات العامه همم
في موضوع
الازدحام مره ثانيه يرجع الازدحام مؤشر
متوسط عدد الدقائق التنقل في المدن الكبرى
ان تخطى الاساسي 77 دقيقه تبغون توصلونه
الى 58 دقيقه شلون
طبعا هذا المده اللي تاخذك من مكانك الى
مكان العمل من بيتك الى عملك يعني والعوده
للعمل والعوده للمنزل
طبعا اليوم
في برنامج جوده الحياه احنا نعمل على انه
يصير عندي خيارات اكثر في من ناحيه العمل
انه ما تضطر انك تطلع من حيك الحي اخر
فانا لما احدث اقتصاديات لما احدث استحدث
قطاعات جديده القطاعات تولد وظائف جديده
قاعد احاول قدر الامكان اني اقلل من حاجتك
للذهاب لمكان بعيد علشان تحصل على وظيفه
فانا قاعده اقلل مده التنقل الخاصه فيك
انه اليوم همم تنوع المشاريع اللي قاعدين
نكون فيها في برنامج جوده الحياه همم
بيعزز من توفر الخيارات ايضا نعمل مع
الجهاز على انه نتاكد انه النقل العام
وهمم اليوم تحت برنامج جوده الحياه ان
النقل العام يصير في طريقه انه يكون جاهز
لكل من يستمع في المدن
يعني انا لما اقول لك انا من 77 دقيقه
طبعا 77 دقيقه هذا كان الخط الاساس الان
المستهدف عندنا 58 دقيقه اخر قياس كان في
2021 59 دقيقه 59 اوه ففي
طبعا انت اليوم ممكن تقول لي
متوسطه
ولي العهد ذكرها انا لما قارن المملكه
مدينه قاعده تزيد بالملايين والمشاريع
الكبيره اللي فيها وقارنها بمدن مليونيه
ثانيه
[موسيقى]
لو سالناكم شرابط بين زواجات الديره
واليهود في نيويورك او حادثه اختطاف
الدمام وجائزه نوبل او مش الرابط بين
كيماوي صدام حسين ومستشفيات الفلبين
الجواب ببساطه
وثائقيه قابلنا فيها علماء من كل المجالات
وصورنا مع شخصيات اثرت الجينات في حياتها
مرحله اسبوعين
انا ابغى اموت
عشان نعرف اجوبه الاسئله
كل يوم مثلا كيف نتعامل مع زواج الاقارب
الله
[موسيقى]
ايه فحاسه
ما نتزوج بعض
وايش بيصير لو حرف واحد بس تغير في
الجيران
وكيف نقدر نعرف روح اسال سؤال ثاني طيب هل
تغلبت الصفات الموروثه على شخص مخطوف وهو
رضيع بسيطه
وش التقنيه المكتشفه من زمان وتعالج كل
امراض العالم
المستخدم
عيونهم خضره شعره اشقر هتلر مين اللي يحط
الماهيه المثاليه هذا هو السؤال كل
الاجوبه بتلاقوها في السلسله جنوب اسبوعيه
على قناه ثمانيه
هذا الملف يعني انت تدري قديش هو مهم ولف
ودار وراح لكل مكان حتى الوطنيه
همم ممكن يصير شايفه الملف شو رايك
كان خط الاساس 44% عن نسبه الرضا
والمستهدف 51% المحقق 57% المحقق 57 اعلى
من المستهدف ايش عرفته وكيف يتغير اللغه
الناس طيب العديد من المخلفات البناء تم
ازالتها العديد من
الجداريات اللي شو ها التامه معالجتها تم
وضع غرامات همم تخصص هذا الجانب فانت
اليوم لما تبني بيت وترمي مخلفات في ارض
ثانيه همم نحط لها حد في هذا الجانب ايضا
الاراضي همم تم الان همم
تصويرها او العمل على تصويرها فجاسين
نعالج هذا الملف طبعا في ملف كبير جدا في
هذا الجانب الان نعمل عليه بانه حتى نحول
هذه المدن المدن اكثر همم يعني ملائمه
للانسان وتكون مستوحات هذه المدن من
هوياتها سمو سيدي ولي العهد الله يحفظك
دائما يؤكد على هويه المدن على ان المدن
كلها قويه
من المدينه نفسها يعني ما هو معقوله اليوم
الرياض تشابه جدا وجده تشابه حائل تشابه
همم جازان وعليها قيس ففي حلول مؤقته
مبدئيه لكن بما ان المملكه قاره في حل
طويل الامد مبني على اكواد بناء واكواد
عمرانيه يعالج هذا الجانب قبل منطقه من
التصوير الحضري هل في شيء من المبادرات
تحب انك تسلط على الضوء بشكل سريع طبعا
انا بتكلم على اليوم مثلا في القطاع
البلدي عندنا دور رئيسي يلعب القطاع الخاص
عندنا اليوم في منصه فرص اكثر من 20,000
فرصه استثماريه موجوده في مختلف مناطق
المملكه الدور اللي يكون فيه قطاع البلدي
ما هو بدور فقط وزاره معينه او برنامج
معين هي شراكه بين الدوله والمواطن في
القطاع الخاص او في القطاع الثالث لمعالجه
همم يعني تشوهات البصريه وللمساهمه حتى في
تحسين مدن المملكه فهي التزام من كل
الاطراف
عشان يكون عندنا التزام عشان نوضح حتى
الفرص او جدنا المنصه فرص اليوم منصه فرص
فيها زي ما قلت لك اكثر من 20,000 فرصه
للقطاع الخاص يقدروا اليوم يدخل ويساهم
فيها وحرصنا انه منصت فرصتها القطاع
البلدي تعمل حتى مع القطاعات الثانيه
فالطرح حتى فرص رياضيه في منصه فرص في
مواقع بلديه فاليوم منصه فرص ادعوا الجميع
انه يدخلوا لها منصه في العديد من الفرج
زي ما قلت لك وبدون القطاع الخاص
والاشتراك القطاع الخاص معنا ما نقدر نكمل
الرحله حالنا بما ان قلبك انت مع الرياضه
خلينا ننتقل لملف الرياضه وايش اهم اتحقق
في مبادرات همم الرياضه طبعا الملف
الرياضه هذا من الملف القطاعات
ان لم تكن مفعله بالطريقه التي تطمح لها
رؤيه المملكه 2030
في الرياضه من هيئه تحولت الى وزاره بنيت
منظومه متكامله في القطاع الرياضي
صار عندي الوزاره ولها مبادراتها صار عندي
اللجنه الاولمبيه وفيها مبادرات صار عندي
تمكين للاعبين صار عندي فعاليات رياضيه
عالميه استضيفه منها اخلق اقتصاد منها
اخلي اللاعبين المحليين او المهتمين يحتكم
بالناس العالميه صار عندي في معهد اعداد
القاده دورات تدريبيه الى الان قربنا فيها
اكثر من 8.000 همم متدرب صار عندي
اكاديميه مهد كيان كامل اهتم بالمواهب صار
في برنامج الابتعات الخارجي
فجينا
للقطاع الرياضي وعملنا على ان القطاع
الرياضي يكون منظومه متكامله بما فيه
القطاع الخاص صار في منصه اسمها منافس
لاصدار تراخيص الرياضيه الكترونيه في
العمل اللي عملناه في همم بالشراكه طبعا
مع وزاره الرياضه بقياده سمو وزير الرياضه
الامير عبد العزيز بن تركي عمل استثنائي
نوع صار في هذا القطاع من القطاع يعني
رياضي همم كان
ممتاز ما يعني ما حكم عليه لكن صار فيه
نقله نوعيه في هذا القطاع في اكثر من 20
فعاليه رياضيه عالميه من برنامج غير
فعاليات اللي تم يمكن تمويلها من خارج
البرنامج فاليوم القطاع الرياضي صار فيه
نقله كبيره في هذا القطاع ولو بتكلم يعني
يمكن بالارقام انا عندي عدد الاماكن اللي
تم تنفيذ الفعاليات والبرامج الرياضيه
فيها خط الاساس في 2017 كان 154 اليوم
1445230 لما اتكلم عن نسبه همم الاشخاص
الممارسين الرياضه شفنا قفزه والقفزه لها
عده همم يعني عده عوامل واعرف ان السؤال
هذا يعني تحبه فاسال فيه همم اعاده تراخيص
المنشات الرياضيه كان خط الاساسي 1259
منصه العام الماضي الى الان عندي اكثر من
2100 اكثر ترخيص ومستهدف العام القادم
2500 فالقفز اللي صارت تقريبا يعني اكثر
من 1400 في سنه ونصف في التراخيص لما اجي
عدد الرياضيين المشاركين في الالعاب
الاولمبيه حققنا المساعده اللي كان موجود
عندنا كان ثمانيه كان سبعه وحققنا ثمانيه
هسه بحقك ثمانيه نعم ثمانيه لاعبين
يتاهلون بدون الفرص المحققه بدون منافسه
اللي هي الوايف كارترز
وما دامك تكلمت على هذه الحين يمكن الواحد
يسال طيب ايش علاقه زوج الحياه في
الفعاليات العالميه هذه الرياضه وزاره
الرياضه سواها انتم طبعا اليوم انت عشان
تقيم فعاليه عالميه وعلى سبيل المثال
فورميلا وان في همم جده
هذه فاعليه
رياضيه ثقافيه ترفيهيه تؤثر في اقتصاد
مدينه جده وشلون انا عندي الرياضه بتقيم
الفاعليه مهنيه بالفعليه نفسها
بالاحراك الرياضي في نفس المكان او السباق
عندي القطاع البلدي يساهم في انه المكان
كامل يتم
خارجيه يتم معالجه التشوهات البصريه تم
الزراعه الارصفه تجهيز المواقف غيره
بالشراكه طبعا مع وزاره الرياضه تحتاج قطع
امني معك
فلازم يكون موجود قطاع امني تحتاج ان
السياحه تهيئ الفنادق
فالسياحه عملت مع الفنادق ان اتاكد من
جاهزيه الفنادق هذه
الثقافه اللي خلقتها رؤيه المملكه يعني
اليوم ما عاد تشوف جهاز معين يمكن هو ماسك
الليد صحيح بس دائما تلقائي طبعا كل مختلف
الجهات الحكوميه علشان يحقق الهدف وهنا
اجت برامج الرؤيه في ايجاد هذه الثقافه من
بدايتها همم يمكن من الاشياء المستخدمه في
موضوع الرياضه همم تجهيز 590 سؤال رياضيه
نسائيه داخل المدارس وتوفير المعلومات هذا
كان المستهدف في 2020 المستهدفاتكم صحيح
طيب هذا من المستهدفات اللي لما رجعنا
ودرسنا هذا المستهدف بدانا نفصل فيه وقت
التنفيذ وتدنا انه في اشياء ما اخذناها في
الحسبان بطريقه مناسبه
590 تحتاج معلمات
برنامج تعليمي لهؤلاء المعلمات علشان نحقق
هذا المستهدف ايضا
عملنا مع المدارس في القطاع الخاص اللي
احنا ما نحتاج انه نروح ونبني الصلاه
وانفسنا بانه يوجدون صالات فيها فقطعنا
شوط كبير في هذا المسادف ما وصلنا لل590
ولكن 590 واللي اهم من انه نحصل لهذا
الرقم تحديدا
وصحققنا المستهدفات الخاصه فيه بطرق اخرى
من خلال اقام الدوري نسائي كان في البدايه
مجتمعي اللي هو النوات اليوم الدوري للاعب
الرسمي تم فتح الصالات الرياضيه والقطاع
الخاص تراخيص بدل ما كانت يمكن قال معالي
بدر القاضي كانت ظهرت رخيصه مشغل قبل
ترخيص رسمي فصار النساء لهم فرص لممارسه
الرياضه في اكثر من مجال فالهدف الرئيسي
اللي نبغى نوصل له في الرؤيا يمكن ما
حققنا ال50 بس في طرق اخرى مباشره
التعليم صح
لم تحقق مشاهده من جانبكم انتم نجلس مع
الوزاره بمشاركه زملائنا في وزاره الرياضه
ونقول وندرس الاسباب اللي منعتنا من تحقيق
هذا المستهدف هل هو سبب تمويل نرجع لوزاره
الماليه وفريق العمل الدائم ونناقش معاهم
هل هو سبب
المعلمات الكافي اللي همم بحيث طبعا
التربيه البدنيه الجديده في المملكه على
القطاع على الفئه النساء
في دبلومات اطلقت الان مشاركه مع الجامعات
انه يحضرون المعلمات في همم التربيه
البدنيه جميل في في اتذكر في الوثيقه صفحه
180 تكلمت عن تاسيس صندوق للرياضه يعني
شفنا الصندوق السياحه
ولكن كنتم تقولون انه نمو القطعه الخاص او
نمكن القطاع الخاص
الصندو صح طبعا احنا اسسها الصندوق
التنميه السياحي صندوق التنميه الثقافي
صندوق التنميه الرياضيه جاي في الطريق
ولكن الى حين الانتهاء من اعتماد
استراتيجيه القطاع الرياضي بيجي بعدها
الصندوق لبناء على الاستراتيجيه بيبدا من
اول للقطاعات معينه ولكن اليوم احنا في
القطاع الرياضي صار في شراكه مع البنوك
صار في شراكه مع برنامج كفاله ما عده
برامج لتوفير خيارات تمويليه بديله في
البديله عن الصندوق فصاحه الصندوق اليوم
مو موجود لكن خيارات التموينيه اغلبها
موجوده من قبل شركات المقاومه مع مختلف
البنوك ومع برنامج كفاله من مبادرات اللي
مره حبيتها بس ما شفت لها شيء موضوع تحفيز
مشاركه الوافدين
لممارسه الرياضه مره حبيت الفكره واشوف
مثلا اذا رحت الاحياء لقيت مثلا مجموعه من
الاسيويين ماخذين لهم برحه وقاعدين يلعبون
فيها كريكت مثلا هذا اللي اشخاص عايشين
معنا ويحتاجون هذا النوع من الخيارات
الترفيهيه وايش اللي تحقق فيها اكيد
بشكل عام سواء في الرياضه وفي الثقافه وفي
غيرها فئه احنا حريصين على اندماجها في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الكريكت اقمنا
اكثر من 30 بطوله حاليا
لكن في اكثر من 30 بطوله اقيمت من الكركيت
مره ثانيه الرياض
اذا ما خانتني الذاكره 95% وافدين
اذا ما خانتني الذاكره في بطولات كثير غير
البطولات اللي طبعا تكون مفتوحه ما هي
مخصصه بس للوافدين يمكن في رياضات معينه
على راس الكريكت هذه اللي خاصه للوافدين
والى الان قمنا فيها زي ما قلت لهم بس
الواحد يرسل لهم قصدي يعني همم
ما شفت سعوديين كثير يماسهم كده مثلا بس
رياضه معروفه عند الجميع
اتحاد الرياضي تغطي كل الالعاب الرياضيه
وفي كل الالعاب وفي اغلبها تغطي همم
بطوله السله في جده اللي صرفناها 3 باي 3
صداقته وزاره الرياضه من احد مبادرات
برنامج جوره الحياه اغلب المشاركين طبعا
المشاركين اللي جاي من بره
لاعبين عالمين لكن الحضور كل الوافدين 90%
وافدين
فعلا
يعني ممتاز اخر مبادره بدي اسالك عنها
مبادره زياده شعبيه الرياضات المختلفه
احنا اليوم عندنا كل الناس كره القدم شوي
شوي طائر بعدها خلاص ما عاد تشوف احد همم
وايش اللي تحقق في زياده شعبيه رياضات
مختلفه طبعا همم
اعتقد انه اليوم لما تيجي وتشوف مثلا
رياضه السيارات في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
جاكار مثلا تحديدا لما بدا في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ومع الوقت كم عدد
السعوديه
احنا في برنامج جوده الحياه
عندنا مراكز تدريب النخبه قاعدين نشتغل
عليها مع وزاره الرياضه لمختلف الرياضيات
عندنا في اكاديميه ما هي مخصصه بس لكره
القدم عندنا الاتحادات الرياضيه
واستراتيجيه الدعم الاتحادات لاطلقناها
لاكثر من 30 رياضه هذه كلها تغطي مختلف
الرياضات ما هي بالقدم
فقاطعين شوط كبير في هذا الجانب والدليل
يعني عدد الاتحادات والالعاب والبطولات
التي قام عدد كبير اخرها الان من اهتمامنا
العاب السعوديه
اطلاق الالعاب السعوديه في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
الامير فهد
الحلقه
السعوديه والهدف منها او بروح ابو عبد
الله الموضوع الثقافه واسالك ايش اهم ما
تحقق في قطاع الثقافه
طبعا احنا كان عدد ايام الفعاليات
الثقافيه خط الاساس كم 188 ااا يوم ثقافي
والمستهدف في 2023- 2093 اشرح لي اول شيء
وش المقصود بالايام الثقافيه كل يوم
فعاليه ثقافيه تقام في المملكه مهرجان
جاكس للفنون درعيه بنادي
نحصر الاشياء
اللي خارج مبادراتنا فكان 188 وبرغم
الجائحه اليوم احنا 1091
الى 1000 الى 1000 و91 بالرغم من الجائحه
ومستهدفنا العام القادم وبنحققه 2093 يوم
ثقافي واخرها موالنا يعني همم الاسبوع
الماضي اكثر من 900 يوم ثقافي جاي في
الطريق
وعدد الخريجين همم
المستهدف 2023 18
اليوم 20,625 في 2021 همم عدد المشاركات
السعوديه في الفعاليات الثقافيه الدوليه
المستهدف 9 بالرغم الجائحه حق قناه خمسه
من هنا الى هنا 2023 بالحقق الاربعه
المتبقيه
فيعني هذه كانت اتكلم على مستوى المؤشرات
على مستوى
من ثقافه تابعه لوزاره الى وزاره تتبع 11
هيئه الى صندوق التنميه الثقافي الى
المنظومه المتكامله الثقافيه في مختلف
القطاعات او المجالات الثقافيه اليوم هذه
كلها موجوده
وعملنا عمل كبير في هذا الجانب اليوم
عندنا فيلم احد الافلام اتصور
بقى يعني يسمح لي ارجع شوي السينما لما
طلقناها ما نبغى بس نطلق السينما يعني
بس يكون عندي شاشه سينما اليوم وتروح انت
تشوفيها تروح تشوف فيها فيلم احنا نبغى
فيلم سعودي
صافي برامج تدريب صار في افلام عالميه
تمويل الجزئيه لتصوير في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه من ضمنها فيلم ذي قار في العلا
وهنا في قصه لطيفه يعني
كان في العلا ففي قصه لطيفه في هذا الجانب
المخرج وهو يصور الفيلم شاف ولد صغير
هذا الولد انه الولد هذا يكون جزء من
الفيلم فاليوم الولد الصغير شعرك في هذا
الفيلم
يعرض عالميا وهذا له مستقبل بكره يكون
ممثل رسمي يعني اليوم ما كان في فرصه هذه
انه فيلم عالم يجي يتصور عندي عملنا برامج
تدريب لمختلف همم
كان مخرج كان كاتب سيناري وكان في اي مجال
من مجالات الافلام علشان نضمن انه فعلا
الافلام تكون متكامله تسال ذلك المسرح
الكتابه
الطهي عندنا مع كوردن بلو تشاركنا
وابتعثنا عدد من الطاهات كلهم اليوم عندهم
اعمالهم خاصه او توظفوا عندنا اليوم هيئه
معانيه للطهي يراسها شخص مهتم في الطهي
نفس الافلام شخص كان يوم عام في المقابلته
هذا الجهاز وعلى ذلك قيس في القطاع
الثقافي وكل القطاعات اللي بنعمل فيها
وهنا تيجي فلسفتنا يمكن في جوده الحياه
انه لما نجي ونشوف وفلسفه الرؤيه نجيء
نشوف القطاع اللي نبغى نستهدفه ونبغى
نلتقي فيه هل هو متكامل انظمه تشريعات هل
في التدريب الكافي هل فيه الممكنات
التموينيه اللازمه اللي تمكن القطاع الخاص
من الاستثمار تراخيص موجوده اللواء سهله
من هنا نجيبه نبني ال ال ال القطاع كامل
ما ادري انا طولت في الاجابه بس عشان
اجاوبتك هذا جزء من
الاجابه وانا بسالك عن مبادره محدده يعني
بعينها مثلا
عندكم مستهدف انكم تنشئون 41 منشاه ثقافيه
خط الاساس في 2019 هو صفر والهدف هو 41 كم
حقنا عام 2021 18 صك باسم وزاره الثقافه
نخلص من مساله لانه تحفر يعني تثبت
بالصقور كلثقافيه لتنقل لوزاره الثقافه
فبنخلص منها وبنحقق الرقم او اكثر ان شاء
الله همم في وحده مبادرات المحوريه
خاصه حسب تصنيف كومنتهم لها مبادره اسمها
انشاء جزيره للفنون والثقافه في جده
يقولون جزيره غرقت
همم في بدايه حديث كنت تقول لك انه في فرق
بين الوثيقه الثانيه ويرجع هذا لامه برامج
او مشاريع ل- همم
استثمارات العامه
فعندي مثل ماعندي الجزيره اللي غرقت
والقريه المائيه يمكن تلقاها في الوثيقه
الاولى
[ضحك]
لان هذه كلها مشاريع اليوم احنا لما نيجي
ندرس مشاريع ااه وعدنا وعدنا فيها في
البدايه او موجوده في وثيقتنا الاولى او
حتى جتنا بعد اطلاق الوثيقه وجدنا افكار
ملائمه
مشاريع بطبيعتها مربحه والطبيعتها الدخل
يعني لها عائد استثماري مع الصندوق
الاستثمارات العامه همم
تم نقل الفكره هذه للصندوق اليوم الصندوق
في شركه وسط جدا بيطلق دار الاوبرا اللي
موجوده في الوثيقه القريه المائيه اعلنت
عنها شركه الجديه قبل تسالني ان كانت
تسالني عنها شركه القديه للاستثمار والجزء
كبير من المشروع وحتى يعني الاخوان في
القديه عملوها بشكل اكبر من اللي كان حتى
احنا نتخيلها وهل تستمروا في متابعه
المستهدف ولا خلاص انتقل منكم راح لي
برنامج عامه طبعا هو راح البرنامج العام
احنا دورنا معهم نتاكد انهم
ماضيين في تنفيذ ولكن المتابع دور اصيل
لمكتب اداره استراتيجيه ولداء الوافدين
هناك في ممارسه الرياضه هي انتم عندكم
مبادره تعزيز اندماج الوافدين والتعرف على
ثقافاتهم وايش اللي يحقق لنا فيها
المبادره عندنا طول العمر والسلامه عندنا
الفعاليات الثقافيه اللي قامناها في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وعندنا عامل خط
العربي
اللي صار العامل الماضي بس ثقافنا احنا
نبغى نتعرف على ثقتهم هم طيب
العجل مره هذا اليوم ههه
[ضحك]
تسلم
عندنا يا طويل العمر والسلامه الفعاليات
الثقافيه اللي استضفناها في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
والفعاليات اللي احنا قمناها يعني عندنا
زي عامل خط العربي لما تشوف عامل خط العرب
اللي اطلق العامل الماضي وبعدين صار في
شراكه ما عده جهات حكوميه يمكن اعلل
ابرزها بالخطاع الرياضي وصار على
التيشيرتات اللاعبين الارقام بالعربي او
الاسماء بالعربي بالعام القهوه اللي صاير
العام هذا و احد مبادرات برنامج جوده
الحياه عام قهوه السعودي الى مشاركتنا في
اللي الفعاليات الثقافيه الخارجيه
واحتضاننا لمهرجان البحر الاحمر السينمائي
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه هذه كلها
تبادل ثقافات انا قاعد ادرس ثقافتي وقاعد
يستقدم ثقافاتهم في مختلف همم
القطاعات الثقافيه في اشياء البرنامج فيها
في اشياء البرنامج بتشارك مع وزاره
الثقافه صارت في اشياء قامت فيها وزاره
الثقافه زي معرض الكتاب الاخير اكثر من
1,000 و200 دار نشر من مختلف الدول العالم
في الدول الاجنبيه فالحراك في هذا الجانب
كبير جدا بس في مثلا عندنا جاليات زي
الجاليات همم الاشقاء المصريين وفي
الباكستانيين وفي الفلبينيين وفي الهنود
هذول الجاليات باعداد ضخمه جدا مئات
الالوف موجودين عندنا همم اتذكر مثلا
واحده من اللمسات الرهيبه في موسم الرياض
الاول كان في حفله همم موسيقيه لمطرب
فلبيني سوداني في العماله المنزليه مثلا
في البيت عندي
يعني كانت اثرها غير عادي عليهم وتعرفهم
على المكان على الناس اللي حاضرين على همم
بعدين مشاركتهم معلومات يعني هذه حتى فتحت
حوار بينه وبينهم انه مين هذا الفنان مش
قصته ايش يسوي همم
فاستهداف فالجاليات اللي مثلا عاداتهم
كبيره عندنا حتى اظن مجدي اقتصاديا لل- من
ناحيه الاعداد اللي موجوده ممكن تستفيد من
الفعاليات هذه هل سويته
همم بالمثال هذا ما امم كمان عملنا شيء
لان احنا عندنا فلسفه في البرنامج او انه
البرنامج اساسا مو بس فعاليات صح برنامج
اعمق من انه نعمل على فعاليات فقط برنامج
عملنا على ضمان انه موجودين في كل
الاعمال اللي نقوم فيها او في غالبها
بتلقاهم اليوم يقدرون يدخلون همم مثلا
بطوله السله اللي صارت في جده من ناحيه
رياضيه كان فيها كثير من الجاليه
الفلبينيه تحديدا
واللي حضر هناك فتح النقاش انه كيف تحبون
اللعبه وكيف اللعبه هذه مهتمه فيها لما
تجيء لي همم الماراثون اللي صار في
الرياضه لما تيجي الدرعيه بنالي كان في
عدد من الاجانب لما تيجي لمختلف الفعاليات
الثقافيه اللي قاعدين فيهم فيها هذا من
جانب الفعاليات من جوانب اخرى عملنا مع
وزاره الموارد البشريه على تحديث نظام
الوافدين في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
احنا قبل حتى نتكلم بس ننظر للكماليات
ننظر حتى الاشياء الاساسيه اللي تساعد من
اندماجهم في المملكه العربيه السعوديه في
عمل كبير يمكن مو بالصوره اللي تراها
كحفله غنائيه لكن في جوانب اخرى قاعدين
نغطيها اا قطاع اخر اللي هو الترفيه قبل
ان انتقل قطاع الاخر فلما بما ان حكينا
على مؤشرات عندي مثلا في عدد مؤلفات
المحليه كان خط الاساس 2,500 في 2019
والمستهدف العام القادم 4,000 انا اليوم
4000 ثلاثه انت عديت المستهدف عدينا
المستهدف العدد المؤلفات المؤلفين
المحليين
عندي عدد المواقع التراث القابله للزياره
كانت 241 العدد اليوم كبير
ما اعلن عن العدد الان لانه جالسين احنا
مع الهيئه بعد الفصل اللي صار بالهيئه
السعوديه للسياحه والتراث الوطني
وانتقالها الاختصاصات للتراث بدانا نعمل
على اعاده تعريف المتاحف بدلنا نعمل على
اعاده تعريف التراث وكيف ممكن تكون قابليه
الزياره العدد فوق يعني فوق المستهدفات
لكن في البرنامج حريصين ان ما نطلع الرقم
لنضمن ان الرقم هذا مرتبط بجوده مع هذا
الرقم
همم في الترفيه
ايش ابرز ما تحقيق
الاماكن الترفيهيه خط الاساس 154
مستهدفنا 2023 345 اليوم نتكلم عن 423
مكان ترفيهي مثل ايش يعني لما تقوم شخص
فيها انا ما اقصد طبعا الاشياء اللي همم
موجوده اليوم مثلا في المواسم انا اقصد
انه اليوم عندي اماكن مخصصه للترفيه على
سبيل المثال ما بدي اذكر اسماء همم
الاماكن التجاريه لكن مكان مصمم في العاب
همم تقدر تروح انت تاخذ ابناءك الصغار
يروحون سواء في مجمع تجاري او في مكان همم
عام يمارسون الترفيه اليوم 423
هذا حسب كوارتر الربع الثاني في 2022
فهذا غطينا فيه المستهدف عدد الفعاليات
الترفيهيه الفريده
المستهدف 40 الى الان محققين 18 عندنا
طبعا احنا بنقول 18 اللي احنا حققناها
موناها غير اللي بره
طبعا عندنا في وسائل الاعلام المتاحه
ومصنف عندنا تحت الترفيه مثل الراديو
والتلفاز والصحافه الخط الاساس كان 113
اليوم نتكلم عن 106 مستهدفنا 150 106 في
2021 المساعده في 150 وصلنا الى الان اذا
ما خلتني الذاكره 140
صار الدروب لانه صار في اعاده ترتيب في
اشياء اغلقت اشياء نظمت
فتم تنظيم هذا القطاع والان احنا مقبلين
على تحقيق المستهدف قبل ان شاء الله وقته
همم نسبه افضل العناوين اللي تم تحتها في
المملكه ونقصد فيها لما ينشر فيلم في
امريكا خلال 90 يوم يكون في المملكه كانت
60% بعد ما قسم بدايه اطلاق السينما ااه
مستهدفنا 80 اليوم 73% تقريبا
2023 كذلك حتى في الالعاب الالكترونيه
الالعاب
كبير يعني نتكلم هنا ممكن ارقام بس لو
بتكلم حتى ايضا على
اللي حصل في القطاع الترفيه صار عندي
برنامج لصنع السعاده يؤخذنا ناس في قطاع
الترفيه تم ابتعادهم مع الجامعات الكبيره
عشان يطورون من مهاراتهم ويحاكون افضل
الخبرات العالميه اللي تخليك ما تتضايق
وانت رايح فعاليه من الفعاليات اللي تبغى
تروح لها لان هذا قطاع جديد عندنا في
المملكه واحبس لنا انه يطور بطريقه مناسبه
ايضا صار فيه برامج مع البنوك مع كفاله
لتمويل القطاع الخاص يعني اليوم عندنا
ترفيه اللي يمكن كان عدد شركات ما يحضر
لنا الرقم كان عدد البسيط بالاشرات اللي
داخله في مجال الترفيه اليوم عندي انا فوق
ال1000 شركه
العمل اللي قاعد يصير في قطاع الترفيه عمل
كبير جدا في هالجانب والتحول فيه كبير
يعني اللي نراها اليوم في المملكه وهذا
جاب بفضل همم طبعا رؤيه المملكه
والتمكين اللي قاعد يصير في هذا القطاع
على التمثيل والشركات القطاع
هل من المستهدفاتكم تزيدون ال ال
الشركات العامله في قطاع او هل هذا من ضمن
الاشياء اللي تهمكم وتخلص منها طبعا احنا
اليوم ااا لما نتكلم عن الترفيه زي ما
تكلمنا عن الرياضه والثقافه انا ما اتكلم
عن الترفيه كماليه
ما هذا جانب لاسعاد المجتمع بجانب زوار من
الخارج للمملكه ينفقون في المملكه علشان
اخلق وظائف اخلاق اقتصاد للمملكه انا
اليوم لما يصير عندي فعاليه ترفيهيه في
مدينه المملكه يزورها زوار من الخارج
معناته في فنادق بتشتغل في محطات بنزينه
بتشتغل في همم مراكز تموين الغذائي بتشتغل
همم في مطارات ممكن تشتغل
موظفين هالقطاعات كلهم بيشتغلوا لخدمه هذا
فاحنا نراها بعد ابعد من فعاليه بحداتها
الى اقتصاد كامل نعمل على صناعته سواء كان
في الترفيه او في الالعاب الالكترونيه
على الاقتصاد بيحقق وظائف ويبي نوع من
اقتصاد المملكه العربيه السعوديه بس يعني
بدانا اقتصاد يحتاج منافسه يحتاج انه في
شركات كثيره تكون لاعبه في هذا القطاع
وتعمل بشكل جيد اللي يسمع من من اللي في
القطاع يقولون احنا كنا ماشيين بشكل رائع
جدا الين جاءت صله
وصارت يعني هي ال ال المحتكر للقطاع وصار
بالنسبه لنا فرصنا فاننا نافس نشتغل نكبر
ما عندي فرس وارده فهل هذا الشيء مثلا
بالنسبه لكم انتم همم ضمن نطاقكم داخل
اهتماماتكم شيء انتم تقدرون تاثروا فيه
ولا ما لكم علاقه فيه لا احنا طبعا لما
قلت همم شركه سنه شركه سالم من شركه
السعوديه اللي نفتخر بوجودها اليوم في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وعملت اعمال كبيره في المملكه يعني همم
من فعاليات الكبيره اللي شفناها في جزء
منها لكن اليوم اغلب الفعاليات اللي قاعد
تشوفها مختلفه يعني في شركات كثير مختلفه
فيها
وممكن يظهر بعض الاسماء لا يعني ما في
اسماء ثانيه من موجوده في من كنتراك
المقاومه الرئيسي في مقاولين تحتهم
واحنا في البرنامج عملنا صناع السعاده
اغلبه شركات ملاك شركات سعوديه اطلعوا
للخارج لتطوير شركاتهم بطريقه احترافيه
عملنا مع برنامج كفاله بنو كانت ما تقرض
على شركات ترفيه اليوم تقرا انت عندك
مشروع ترفيهي تقدر تدخل مع البنوك بطريقه
اخرى من البرنامج
فاحنا لا حريصين ان ما يكون في احتكار
شركه معينه واذا كان في شركه معينه محتاج
له اليوم السوق اعتقد هذه المعلومه قد لا
تكون دقيقه 100% لانه فعاليات كثير
ومختلف في المملكه كانت ترفيهيه او ثقافيه
او رياضيه
همم
1322 مطعم جديد
و1127 جديد
الحجاقه احنا همم مكيف عدد الافراح النسبه
وتناسب الان
نسبه المطاعم للافراد فاليوم المستهدف 3.2
ل 2023 في 2020 3.1
فاحنا
هذا اخر قياس كان المؤشر فالقياس القادم
متاكدين 100% انه همم من حقق الرقم
المطلوب همم والدليل عدد المطاعم بالعين
المجرده تشوفها زاد المقاهي زادت صار فيه
تحول في هذا القطاع وجالسين حتى نعمل انه
المطاعم ما تكون بس بطريقه التقليديه او
المقاهي بالطريقه التقليديه ونستفيد من
هذه المقاعد في مقاهي ثقافيه يكون فيها
بيع كتب ادخال الكتب فيها يكون فيها
ممارسه فنون ثقافيه معينه اما رسم او غناء
او غيرها فنبغى نحول حتى مفهوم يعني هدفنا
مو بس نصر العدد العدد وصلنا له الهدف
الان غير المفهوم انه هذه المقاهي تتحول
الى مقاهي ثقافيه جاذبه بفئه ثقافيه معينه
همم واحده من الاهدافكم
تاسيس 450 نادي للهوات بحدود 2020 اللي
انا متاكد من 21 20 عدد انديه الواتس صح
اليومتين بس ليش 20 20 طيب يعني اربع
سنوات 2016
حريصين انه ما يكون التسجيل لقطاعات معينه
بدون قطاعات ثانيه نضغط توسع وتنوع في
الهوات ما نبغى الهاوي ياخذ صبغه معينه
بقطاع معين فحرسين انه يكون فيه اهواك من
مختلف الهوايات
وربطنا بمركز المعلومات الوطني ووجود
الجهات المختلفه ضمنت لنا انه هذا الهاوي
معروف
بياناته معروفه يساهم في مكان امن موافقات
اللي يحتاجها لممارسه هوايته كانت في اي
مكان يقدر ياخذها من خلال المنصه المنصه
الان موجوده ادعوا الجميع ان يزور
المنصوره
طيب شيء سؤال جميل اليوم همم في هاوي انت
الان عندك هوايه معينه هذه الهوايه قد لا
تعرف مين يشارك في الهوايه
قد لا تثق في اللي شعرك فكره روايه فانت
اليوم لما تروح تسجل في هذه المنصه اول
شيء تقدر توثق الاعضاء اللي معك في منصه
امنه تقدر تستقطب اعضاء اهوات لهذه المنصه
ما حبيت تتاسس النادي تقدر تدخل تشوف
النادي اللي يمثل هوايتك وتطلع
احنا الان
تعطيني مرافق ولا تعطوني اعطيك اكثر
نعطيك همم تقدر تاخذ موافقات على استخدام
مرافق معينه وهنا عملنا مبادره لحصر
الاصول الحكوميه الغير مستغله حصرنا فيها
اكثر من 100 اصل ربطناها بهاوي فمن خلال
هواوي تقدر تشوف صوره المكان حجم المكان
وتستاجر
المكانك احنا حتى تحتاج ادوات اذا انت
مثلا رسم لكن يوم تناديك ما تقدر ما عندك
الامكانيات الماديه انك تجي ادوات الرسم
اللي تبغاها هاوي اليوم يوفر لك البدايات
اللي تمكنك من تاسيس هذا النادي تحتاج
دورات تدريبيه في مختلف المجالات نوفر لك
الدورات التدريبيه اللي تحتاجها تاخر
المشروع ولكن تاخر لبناء منظومه متكامله
تاكدنا انه الهاوي مبكر الهاوي امن موفق
في بيئه امنه ممكنه له لممارسه هواياته
وبتشوف الايام القادمه بمشيئه الله العديد
من الحملات اللي تبين هذا القطاع يعني
يمكن انا شويه اخرت الزمن عندي في
البرنامج انه قلت لهم ابغى اتاكد بس انه
فعلا هذا القطاع مبني بطريقه صحيحه حظيره
جدا همم
الامن وبعده ممكن يعني على السياحه بشكل
سريع في الامن في معدل حالات القتل العمد
واحد ونصف من كل مائه الف
ونبغى نوصلها او نبقى نحفظها لا واحد
فاصله ثلاثه من كلمات الف
وش اللي حققناه في الجانب وش علاقتكم انتم
بهذا المستهدف او هذا المؤشر طيب احنا
اليوم اليوم امنك الشخصي
في يعد جانب من جانب من جوانب جوده الحياه
اليوم
ممارستك لرياضه معينه ولا لي هوايه معينه
ولا ثقافه معينه ولا حضورك فعاليه ولا
سفرك طبيعي يستلزم بيئه امنه ففي برنامج
جوده الحياه حرصنا مع شركائنا طبعا في
وزاره الداخليه انه نعمل على هذه المنظومه
بديناها بتسعه واحده اللي كلمتك قبل شويه
ورده وفي شيء الان نعمل معاهم عليه انه
حتى نسبه الاستجابه على ارض الواقع تكون
ضمن معدلات العالميه يعني اما كانت العفو
العالميه
شلون
بدينا الان ممكن وقعنا الان ااا اعلنت قبل
فتره بسيطه ثلاثه اتفاقيات رئيسيه منها
مركز شرطه رائد منها الشرط المتحركه بمعنى
اليوم انا عندي زحمه او ازدحام لسبب
فعاليه او او لاي سبب في منطقه معينه ما
عاد تحتاج تروح ابني مركز شرطه بابني مركز
شرطه متنقل يروح لهذا المكان عشان اضمن
انه الامن منضبط في هذا المكان عندي ايضا
همم المدن الامنه والكاميرات في المدن
جالسين نعمل على هذا الجانب
كل هذه تعالج مو بس حالات القتل العمد
تعالج مستوى الجريمه ومستوى الثقه في
الخدمات الامنيه والحمد لله ترى مستويات
المرضيه جدا يعني نتكلم على ارقام كبيره
الى درجه انه ما ودي والله اقولها لكن
يعني من من الحمد لله هذا من الاشياء اللي
الله فضلنا فيها في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
من مدن من المدينه الى المدينه امنه
فارقنا جدا ماضيه الصراحه في القطاع
الامني همم في السياحه يعني وان كان هذا
ضيف جديد عليكم بس مش اهم ما تحقق فيها ما
عاد في وظائف جديده
[ضحك]
السياحي يمكن اخر شيء شفناه منظمه السياحه
العالميه لما طلعت في تقريرها انونس بس
النمو مقارنه ب 2019 121% وهذا رقم جميل
جدا
ما خانتني الذاكره اخر رقم وصلنا مليون
تاشيره سياحيه عدد الزيارات في ارتفاع
عندنا في مستهدفنا في القطاع السياحي اللي
هو خلق مليون وظيفه
وباستاذنك اني اجيب الرقم بالضبط
طبعا احنا في عدد الزيارات
المستهدف 56 مليون زياره في 2023 في سنه
2023 في 2021 67 مليون زياره لما اتكلم عن
عدد موظفين المباشرين في قطاع السياحه كان
المستهدف 722000 وخط الاساس 579,000 اليوم
854000 انا تجاوزت المساجد اكثر من
100,000
وظيفه
عندي مليون و600 مليون و600 الف وظيفه
لانه خط الاساس
57923 في او تعدينا بالاصح المستهدف الخاص
فيها
في القطاع السياحي اليوم المنظومه متكامله
تسويقيه وترويج المملكه موجوده الهيئه
السعوديه للسياحه
الوزاره بالتشريعات والانظمه
الصندوق بدعم القطاع الخاص واخر رقم يعني
اخذتها من زملائي في صندوق التنميه
السياحي 200 مليون 17 مليار حجم
قيمه المشاريع المموره قيمه المشاريع
المنوره 17 مليار ما خلتني الذاكره طبعا
دائما
صغيره
يعني الحمد لله ما اخذ الدرجات عاليه بس
تجيني في الاشياء اللي فيها حفظ الذاكره
المشاريع طبعا مختلف مناطق المملكه الى
حتى يعني
سؤال في بدايه الحلقه عن بعض المدن انه هل
اهتمامنا في مدن الرئيسيه واحده من
الاتفاقيات اللي حضرناها في برنامج جوده
الحياه كانت في الباحه في منتزه رغدان
شراكه بالصندوق التنميه السياحي واحد
شركات القطاع الخاص لاقامه فندق مميز في
هذه المنطقه فاليوم المشاريع السياحيه
والتمكين اللي موجود للقطاع السياحي
وطبعا
العامل الرئيسي اللي بيحدث هذا التغيير هو
القطاع الخاص نتيجه الطلب اللي قاعدين
يرتفع بشكل ملاحظ على المملكه من ناحيه
الزيارات السياحيه اتذكر واحده من مبادرات
كانت تطوير جزيره الراس الابيض
في المدينه المنوره
شخصيا
وراحت الصوره يمكن
بمعالي احمد الخطيب وارسلها حتى اعتقد سمو
الامير بدر
وصار هناك في وقفه للكويت الجزيره
[موسيقى]
ذكر مزروع المزروع كان المتحدث الرسمي
باسم البرنامج
كانه مقابله مع
عبد الرحمن ابو مالك كان يقول لسه ما
قررنا من سيتولى مهمه التقييم او ما يسمى
بالمشتري الخفي لتقييم تجربه ال ال ال
الشخص في اغلب هذا المرافق سواء ارصفه
شوارع ولا فعاليات فاليوم مين اللي يقيم
تجربتي انا كعميل في كل هذه ال ال البرامج
والمبادره مؤشر لجوده الحياه مع منظمه
دوليه سيتم الاعلان عن قريبا تو تم توقيعه
ولكن
اوكي اوكي
طبعا في ادوات اخرى موجوده يعني على
المؤشرات الكبيره يعني همم
الجوده في الصبيانات نتلاقى خفيه كثير
همم ولكن في عمل كبير لمؤشر من هذا الجارح
همم هذه مجموعه مناسبه الاصدقاء شاركوها
معنا واحد يقول همم انتم قاعدين تخربون
جوده حياتي انا مهتم بالرياضه ابغى اجي
احضر مباراه تشغلوا لي فيها حفلات غنائيه
ليش انا ما بسمع اغاني ففي شريحه
المحافظين زعلانين منكم سحبين عليهم ما في
شيء مخصص لهم كل شيء يكون فيه يعني تفاصيل
معينه تناسبهم فهمم شلون تصممون برامجكم
هل ترعون هذا الشريحه ولا ولا ما تبونهم
احنا في برنامج جوده الحياه
عملنا الرئيسي اني استخدم خيارات كثيره
لكل فئات المتابعه
اليوم في مختلف مدن المملكه تجربتك مختلفه
عن تجربتك ما قبل الرؤيه اليوم عندك
خيارات في الترفيه عندك خيارات في الرياض
خيارات في المطاعم في المقاهي في الثقافه
في مختلف الفعاليات ممكن الفعاليات فيها
اغاني مثال على ذلك
في سباق رياضي قائم همم الناس تجيء وتحضر
السماء في حفلات خيريه
فالخيارات موجوده
في فعاليات انا استحدث خيارات واممكن
القطاع الخاص من استحداث خيارات
والقطاع الخاص يدرس الطلب والعرض اللي
موجود في السوق وبناء عليه همم
فعاليات كامله ما فيها همم
احنا عندنا يعني تصاريح تاخذها الكترونيا
هو انا بكل الفعاليات فيها حفلات غنائيه
ولو اني يعني ما ودي ادخل في هذا الجانب
في ناس شرعيه مختصين اكثر مني
من يضع ارقام المؤشرات ولماذا البحث بعضها
طموح جدا هل تموت الحقيقه 70% من الهدف
همم يمكن ذكرت لك في بدايه او في خلال
الحلقه انه 98% تظهر اصفر 100%
كلها مباشره
من قبل اللجنه الاستراتيجيه وعلينا الوفاء
والالتزام بتحقيقه وفي حال واجهنا اي تحدي
نرجع الاستراتي ونقول احنا عندنا هذا
التحدي في تحديات مشتركه تنفيذيه نقول انا
والله مثلا ما لقيت شغل الفلانيه
ممثليه
همم
ليش ما شفنا الحساب الوطني
هذا هذا الحسابات لوكاله الانباء السوريه
هل يقدر يعطيني ارقام ملموسه حول خفض نسبه
التعاطي المخدرات في السعوديه هل هذا
الشيء اللي انتم تشتغلوا عليها هذه من ضمن
الاهداف اللي اسندت لنا مؤخرا اجدد ضعف
علينا
يعني
وان شاء الله انه القياده راضي عن اداءنا
في برنامج جوده الحياه ولهم حتى استنقاسم
في البرامج الاخرى
اللجنه المقام اللجنه الاستراتيجيه انه
يسند هذا الهدف لنا في برنامج جوده الحياه
والان احنا في طور استحداث مبادرات خاصه
لهذا الهدف هذا من ضمن الاهداف المستحدث
يعني المقوله اننا مؤخرا ما في عندكم قياس
حالي عندنا حمله حملات اعلاميه الان مقيم
همم يعني نعمل عليها قياس هذا الهدف من
ضمن التحديات اللي يعني للامانه ايه
نواجهها وتواجهها كل دول العالم اليوم
تعاطي المخدرات مختلفه عن طريقه تهريب همم
الاستخدامات ماذا معرفه او غير متعاطي
اختلفت ادوات التعاطي ادوات تهريب
المخدرات الله يكفينا الشر
الان نعمل على استراتيجيه انه كيف ممكن
نكافح هذا الجانب بالاضافه لانه ثقافتنا
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه ثقافه تميل
الى المحافظه يعني انت لما تكون تعرف شخص
لا سمح الله مدمن قليل من الناس اللي ممكن
يبادر بالتبليغ ولا يبادر خوفا على السمعه
خوفا فهذا الجانب بصراحه يعني واجهنا فيه
تحدي وجالس النعمه اللي عليه ان شاء الله
باذن الله في قبل الاخير سؤال على لو انا
مهتمه جدا مبادرات او افكار او مقترحات
كيف اقدر اوصلها لكم طبعا في موجود اليوم
موقع الرؤيه في كل البرامج رؤيه المملكه
في قنوات التواصل مع هذه البرامج همم
ونستقبل فيها العديد من همم العديد من
الرسائل والافكار المساعدتنا للامانه في
عملنا
ايضا في كل ما نقيمه من مشاريع نحرص ان
يكون في اداء ايصال همم صوت
المجتمع ونسمع الصوت نسمع يعني اراهم
وافكارهم من خلال حضورها في مختلف الفعالي
طب مختلف المشاريع وعندنا ايضا
يعني غير انه الناس تتكلم معنا في فكره
كذا طلعنا فيها شوي غريبه
حراصا حتى في التواصل ان نتواصل مع
الاجيال القديمه لاجينا من خلال زي المعهد
الملكي للفنون التقليديه انا ابغى انقل
ثقافات القديمه للثقافات للمجتمع الجديد
لما اتكلم عن عامل القهوه السعودي واصل
ثقافه الاباء والاجداد في الاجيال الجديده
وعلى ذلك قيس فيعني التواصل من مختلف
الجهاز ونوفر الادوات التواصل حتى بين
الاجيال مش اكثر مبادرات متحمس لها في
2023 هل سنه مدن المملكه همم بمشيئه الله
العمل الكبير اللي قاعدين نقوم فيه مختلف
لان اسمعها من خمس سنوات
نظري مذنب بشعه بشعه جدا ممله ما هي
بصديقه الانسان الواحد ما يقدر يتمشى فيها
ما يقدر ياخذ سيكل يروح المسجد ابسط مشوار
البسيط حق المسجد
نمط الحياه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
انا مطرحها او مشاريع نمط الحياه بشكل
اداء سهل انك تلامس فيها الناس سهل
الاحداثها بعكس مشاريع البنيه التحتيه
اللي تاخذ وقت طويل
مشاريعنا ومشاريع صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه ومختلف مشاريع الدوله كلها تستهدف
تغير شكلنا عندنا اواسطه المدن اللي اطلقت
من صندوق همم الاستمارات العامه عندنا
راحت لكل المناطق المملكه
المشاريع المقاومه في الرياض بالاضافه الى
المشاريع اللي احنا نعمل الان مع وزاره
الشؤون البلديه والقرويه والاسكان ومع
هيئات التطوير للان استحدثت في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه عدت من هيئات التطوير
كلها اليوم موجوده يعني تم اضافتها في
عضويه لجنه البرنامج
بيمثلهم معالي المهندس ابراهيم السلطان
فصار الان هذا يعني شغل شغل معهم نحدث
المشاريع نوعيه تغير من شكل المدن طبعا
هذا بناء على اهتمام وتوجيه اسمه سيدي
كل الحرص على تغيير شكلنا 23 عامل الانسان
بدايه اطلاق ان شاء الله مشاريع السنه
باذن الله شكرا ابو عبد الله على قبول
الدعوه وبالتوفيق في تجويد حياتنا
شاكر لكم هذه الدعوه الكريمه وان شاء الله
ان يوفقت يعني في هذه الحلقه
انقل عدد من الاشياء اللي قمنا فيها
الجهات التنفيذيه مشكوره معانا ما قصرت
شكرا لك حياك الله شكرا لكم
الكاميرات في تسجيل الصوت عبد العزيز
المسجد وفي التحرير انس الخليل وفي
الهندسه الصوتيه محمد حسن
غلط
احد من منتجات شركه ثمانيه للنشر والتوزي
[موسيقى]